hey this is prashta walker
martin is a gardener in math land
there are a hundred poisonous flowers in
his garden that he wants to destroy
on their own the flowers do not change
in number
martin has a spray to kill the poisonous
flowers
but the spray works only in a specific
way
the spray has settings to destroy
exactly 3
5
14 or 17 flowers instantly
the spray only works if there are at
least as many flowers as the setting
if there are two flowers for example the
setting for three does nothing
furthermore if at least one flower
survives after he sprays them
the flowers instantly grow back based on
how many died
if three die then 12 grow back if 5 die
then 17 grow back
if 14 die then 8 grow back
and if 17 die true grow back
if the number of flowers is ever exactly
zero
then the flowers never grow back
can martin ever get rid of the poisonous
flowers in his garden
you can assume he has an unlimited
amount of
spray can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
so from the initial hundred flowers
you can try experimenting the different
combinations of the flowers you can
spray and keep track of how many flowers
remain
but no matter how you try you're not
going to be able to get rid of all the
flowers
we can understand why by thinking
forward and reasoning backwards
so in order for martin to succeed there
needs to be 3
5 14 or 17 flowers
just before the last time he sprays the
flowers
this means from the initial hundred
flowers
martin has to decrease the number of
flowers by exactly 97 95 86 or 83
flowers
let's consider the net change after each
setting of the spray
if he uses a setting of 3
he kills 3 but 12 grow back
which leads to plus 9 flowers
for the setting of 5 there is a net
change of plus 12 flowers
for 14 setting he decreases the number
of flowers by 6 and for the 17th setting
he decreases the number of flowers by
15.
on each setting of the spray martin can
only change the number of flowers by
plus nine plus twelve minus six or minus
fifteen
and there's a pattern to these numbers
they are all multiples of three
since martin only changes the number of
flowers by a multiple of three
the number of flowers has to change by
3x for certain integer values of x
now since the numbers 97 95 86 and 83
are not multiples of 3 that means martin
is not capable of decreasing the initial
number by exactly any of those numbers
therefore we can conclude martin can
never get rid of all of the poisonous
flowers
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description